[Applause]
and finally new rule for 2024 America
has to go back on its
meds you know over the holidays I saw a
lot of people and I asked them all the
same two questions one have you seen
Woody harlson he's my
ride and two if I said let's make
2024 the year of blank what would you
say I was surprised they all said the
same thing sanity let's make this the
year of Sanity everybody thinks we've
gone
bunkers and a lot of it is because the
far ends on both left and right have
gotten way too much attention which begs
the question how do you suck all the
oxygen out of the room and still not get
any to your
brain
I I feel like it wasn't that long ago
when you could watch watch cable news
for a day and not get the impression
that this whole place was totally
batshit that simply was not America
Florida yes but not
America so let's examine what makes sane
people feel this way sane people who are
after all still the vast majority and
who are the ones who I assume just voted
me the most trusted man in America that
is a real
headline thank you
just call me Billy
cronite anyway what does what does
strike a sane person as crazy I don't
know if you can ask me I would start
with the fact that I still occasionally
see someone driving along lawn with a
masc
on who who do they think they're going
to get it from the lady in the next car
putting on her
makeup or
maybe I would say it's the continuing
debt sealing debate every time a
Democrat is President the Republicans
threaten to tank the world economy by
forcing us to take a vote on whether to
pay back the money we already spent no
the country does this it's like eating
at a restaurant and then taking a vote
on whether to dine and
dash
and and whoever the Republicans make
Speaker of the House if he doesn't vote
for dash which he really can't do in the
job they just gave him they try to get
rid of him Congress isn't a deliberative
body anymore it's a rave without a
permit in a burning paint
Warehouse
insane
but probably the first thing on my and
most people's list of insanity is that
this guy is going to be president again
it feels surreal that we're in court
every day trying to prove Trump wanted
to overturn the election while he's on
the campaign Trail every day telling
everyone they should have overturned the
election it also strikes normal people
as inane that Trump fans are perfectly
okay with the fact that he was recently
asked to be wanted to be a dictator and
he did not say
no neither did his lawyer say no when a
judge asked him could a president who
was not impeached order SEAL Team Six to
assassinate a political rival the
lawyer's answer was a qualified
yes okay these are not brain
teasers neither should it have been
difficult when presidents of elite
colleges were asked if it's okay to call
for the genocide of Jews and they
couldn't just say no can't anybody
just say no
anymore does does anybody even know who
to root for anymore a store manager at
Lululemon tried to stop some shoplifters
last year and the CEO fired her fired
the person trying to stop Robbers from
robbing his store that's crazy but this
is crazy too if you rob a store you can
fully expect to be shot as you are
leaving that
store
[Applause]
shot really we can't come to some sort
of Middle Ground
on any
issue socially liberal but not stupid
woke fiscally sane but not cruel is this
really that hard trans people should be
respected and protected but no penises
in women's prisons maybe legalized pop
and maybe stop giving drugs to hard drug
addicts Nikki Haley says America's never
been racist and social justice Warriors
say there's been no progress since Amos
and
Andy a terrorist organization in the
Middle East that treats women like
slaves invaded Israel last October and
shot hundreds of young people at a music
festival in the desert and now America's
streets are full of parades in support
of the
shooters led by the exact kind of people
who would be at a music festival in the
desert
that's the literal standard for
involuntary commitment when you're a
danger to
yourself I
mean the the NRA are bad but after a
school shooting they don't March against
schools thank you one
guy
the the far left's new crush is the
hooti
up until a week ago everyone on Tik Tok
thought a houthi was what you get when
someone hit your elbow W gave me a
houie
d and the houthi slogan is God is great
death to the US death to Israel curse
the Jews and victory for Islam like
comment and
subscribe so naturally when the college
kids heard that slogan they said please
stop you had me a death to the
US
insane insane that we're cheering for
the terrorist now it's also insane to
think that
this would ever come out
well
right and it's also insane to feel that
it's important to try and prove that
Taylor Swift is
gay which apparently is what the
supposedly most esteemed newspaper in
America feels is very important to
do that that's that's so insane I don't
even get it if if Taylor Swift is gay
what this this is somehow a better
country the farle now insists men can
have babies if they just concentrate
hard and don't listen to the
haters does that make us a better
country no and neither does persecuting
a pregnant woman who wants to get an
abortion for a fetus doctors say will
not survive could everyone just stop
being nutty completely nutty for five
minutes the battle for the soul of this
country isn't right or left it's normal
versus
crazy